the mall is with us in Texas hey Jamal
how are you I'm good how about you
better than I deserve what's up
I got a huge mess of my hand I was
hoping you can help me
Ultra I have six hundred twenty-two
thousand dollar real dollars six hundred
thirty two thousand and what 22 thousand
inland in loans on what credit card and
business loans how much is credit card
and how much is business 297,000
business and three hundred twenty five
thousand credit card so you ran your
business on the credit cards too then
yes okay how's the business doing
business was doing okay and then last
year they started to not doing okay so I
make less and less money revenue went
down it's two stores and I can actually
sell one of the stores and then if I run
one store I can make four or five
thousand a month
what kind of stores what do they do
grocery stores and cell phones okay and
I used to have a good online sales and
that went down and they got everything
and to top all of that I'm going through
divorce
and that is well not to blame on it but
I made some huge stupid this yearly last
two three years that accumulated the
death so now I am at a stage where I can
make minimum payments it's been almost
two months where I haven't made pay me
to half of them I can get some money
together by selling the store like
thirty forty thousand and then I can get
four or five thousand a month savings
but I don't know how to start an indoor
will sell for only thirty or forty
thousand each I know the one I'm selling
will sell about thirty forty thousand
the one I'm planning to keep and run
they'll sell about hundred thousand
what did you do before you open these
doors
I was IT consultant okay and what
happened to online sales and how much
were they the online fields I was doing
about million a year for last four years
top line would you net on that yeah
about 15 percent fifteen to thirty
percent what happened with that
what was it running now and now it's
running it was very very smooth down it
was running about two hundred fifty
thousand a year but they're not gonna
after I stopped paying these crazy they
put a hold of me online accounts so now
it's zero
they put a hold on your online account
yes couple of the business creditors
they had a UCC filed at my business so
they sent a UCC to the online
marketplace detail and eBay and Amazon
and they hold my account so I can't sell
online anymore you can but it all goes
to the creditor right exactly yeah okay
why did your sales go down online I I
was counting up new suppliers I was
dealing with them for like about six
seven years and they stopped dealing in
the laptop that I was buying from them I
had couple of suppliers couple of
wholesale customers my net set up every
month I was doing pretty good with that
and all of a sudden both of the supplier
they stopped dealing in computers and I
was just buying Big Lots from them
cleaning it up and selling is that in
the e-cigs
during the day I was running my store
okay it sounds like that your online has
always been with the exception of lately
the most successful part of your
business
yes I actually I think these stores were
a dumb idea and became a distraction to
us to a successful online business
sounds that create value hmm so I wonder
if you couldn't what the creditors that
took the UCC one what do you owe them is
that the 297 oh yeah whole amount the
297 is divided among six okay what's the
clear though what's it take to clear
that creditor with the UCC 1000 okay so
I wonder if you don't crank up your
online sales again and go source that I
think the reason you lost all of that
was the normal course of business is
attrition with suppliers and with
customers you're constantly having to
reset suppliers and constantly have to
reset new customers that's the normal
rhythm of business I think you were
distracted by your home life and by your
stores and you took your eye off the
ball on that and I think if you focused
again real intently on the online side
you might get up and get that you see
see one guy paid by just raising your
sales online that clear him and get some
income coming in because you're your
highest income potential that you've
outlined here is not the sale of stores
it's Greek it's restarting and revamping
in reviving your old online business it
was the one that was the it was the cash
king all right yeah that's exactly right
that was my bread and butter now might
be concern is now where I'm making you
know if I put like a real good effort I
can clear this you see see yeah but what
happens in the next guy filed at UCC
well the credit cards aren't gonna do
that they're just gonna sue you some of
them and it'll be six months more and
then you know what you're going to do
your goal is to court plough through the
297 first and then go back and clean up
the credit cards I just stopped paying
the credit cards you got aside who
you're not gonna pay anyway you can't
pay somebody so don't pay any credit
card yet that that was one of my
question that is yeah I stopped because
I moved my business to cash now yeah and
but I think you doing minimum payments
on the cards and if I stopped them can
they get hold of my bank account
eventually they'll see you and they
could take a lien on stuff but you'll
get around to them faster than that if
you can get your income back up to a
couple hundred a year
which you have done before but yeah the
way I see it if I can like do all that
it's going to take me probably 18 months
to two years yep yep
it's verifies either that or file
bankruptcy that was my thing like yeah
well my biggest concern is that if I do
on that effort and then they put a lien
on my bank account now I can't run like
this well you'll go back and get it
cleaned up you can sell these credit
cards for 25 cents on the dollar once
they go bad I'm not suggesting that that
was a good plan but it's where we are
and you can go back and clean them up as
the last step in cleaning up this 600
grand and so you clean off the other
stuff first and then you go back and you
work those credit cards and you just
work the the one that's the most
aggressive legally not the most
aggressive on the phone they'll wear
your butt out on the phone
it's just how its nature yeah that
they're just they're nasty and so you
just have to hang up on them and move on
with your day but because you know
you're gonna do the rest you if you
don't work this plan you're bankrupt so
you got to work some kind of a plan
where they don't get paid so that they
get paid right that's what you're facing
so yeah I mean you can file and just
start fresh and just you know turn the
keys over the stores and walk away from
the whole thing and you know and you're
going through a divorce and everything
is a whiteboard in your life you just
get a fresh start on everything go back
to IT for a while lick your wounds get
healed start your life over you can do
all of that I always recommend with
bankruptcy that it's like divorce that
you do everything you can to keep from
doing it and when you've done all you
can do if you still are forced into it
then at least you don't have the regret
of I just willy nilly just tossed in the
keys on something as big and
life-changing as those things are you
want to know that you did everything
possible to avoid it and then you don't
have regret I want I can tell you at the
time with what I knew at 28 years old
with the creditors chasing me when I was
going bankrupt I fought it for
two-and-a-half years and I repaid most
of the debt during that time but I still
got boxed into a
and I didn't know what to do and I ran
out my emotional and spiritual gas tank
was completely empty
I was completely freaking out and
terrorized and with everything I had
done all I knew today so I have no
regrets I tried everything I knew to do
I late I didn't I left it all on the
field and so I don't look back and go
well I was just a bad guy who didn't pay
his bills no I did everything I could do
and you want to be able to say that to
yourself in the mirror that's what I
want for you